[Music]
now to what appears to be an imminent
engagement between Megan Marco and
Prince Harry here she is smiling and all
bundled up in what looks to be her new
home of London it's the first sighting
of the 36 year old since reportedly
wrapping production of her final season
of suits last Friday in short she is
planning to make a full time move now
over to the UK I would say this is
probably the most significant thing to
happen yet in their relationship it is
expected Megan will move in to Prince
Harry's two-bedroom cottage in
Kensington Palace while there are
rumours the couple may already be
secretly engaged a royal expert Katie
Nichols says don't expect any official
announcement for a few months it really
is all about the timing and you have to
remember that there are other
engagements and events coming up in the
royal calendar that an engagement simply
couldn't clash with I think the new year
is probably a more realistic prospect
for an engagement announcement
[Music]